he gets black yeah yeah and he starts
with Knight F3 James that's a solid
start when you need a draw to win the
match of course you need to go King's
Indian here big fella something very
strange and for some change okay you're
gonna have to make it happen here or
you're going I mean you're going You're
Gonna not eliminated but you get to the
losers bracket here it's gonna be tough
to see Magnus in the limit in the the uh
the lose breakfast so it's pretty tough
thesaurus right G6 we got Bishop G2
Bishop G7 come on let's see a D4 D6 D6
D6 Magnus D6 he's willing him James is
willing Magnus to go do you think it
might happen
is there it is
it's a dub it's a dub it's a win okay
good we're good knight C3 this is a
strange variation of course they usually
go with like A4 here too as well so this
is a strange one but you can get lots of
play kid is is you know when you need it
when you go for kid and that's
definitely something that we're going to
see from Magnus here the World Champ
hopefully he's able to strike so yeah
tell me if we'll try and Bully Magnus
with the thought of equality with a
thought of a draw with a thought of an
endgame even and uh it's rare to say
that but yeah tell me I've can
definitely use the odds which are
stacked in his favor now to uh push
Magnus in certain directions and this
last move already forcing Magnus to
think that white a pawn is going to push
itself even further up the board if
given the opportunity or it can also
occupy the center anytime we uh he wants
there we go uh the pawn really clamping
down on that black queen side and Magnus
okay he looked away he doesn't look too
unhappy but a bit of an odd one I've got
to say this last queen movie what is
that David Queen D3 uh don't ask me
Roman hey that was a good rhyme there
but don't want to be the one to answer
the question it doesn't really make so
much sense I think he's just waiting for
Magnus to strike in the center and when
he does with E5 or C5 some kind of Pawn
break he'll slide is Rook to D1 so I
just think that our tentative does not
want to commit his pawns forward because
as soon as you push your pawns forward
you may create some weak squares that
you can't deal with so well so I think
artemium he's just keeping everything
tame for the time being but he kind of
has to do something at some point that's
a very good point actually that's really
good strategy because so much went wrong
with white and you just calm your nerves
a little bit put it behind you get ready
for a new format get into that mindset
you're not gonna lie that's probably the
worst King's any I ever seen in my life
bro and I mean Magnus not a real King's
Indian player like he don't actually
really play it like that he can't he can
play anything but he doesn't play like
he's playing the king's Indian
positionally and that's just not what
you're supposed to do with Kings Indian
but and it is not looking good this
amazing look at this Knight oh man this
is rough this is a rough King's India
yeah what a move what an instructive
move there from vladislav I'll tell me
if even in a situation where he's happy
with the draw he's definitely going for
the most principled options this last
move it looks like you're slightly
loosening the white king weakening the
shelter around it but the most important
point is to dominate that black knight
that Black Knight on H6 is going to take
an age to get back in the game in the
meantime vladislav will have asserted
domination will have got over all of his
pieces to dream squares Magnus
desperately trying to ask questions try
to open up lines for his pieces but
there must be a way here it feels like
white has so much space there must be a
way to shut things down uh Block in
Black's pieces even further this last
move was good though from like S6 right
break it open black will bring his
pieces back to life now the Black Knight
has a route back towards the center the
black pawn will step forward opening up
this king's Indian Bishop again on the
long diagonal okay he's gone for the
safe approach no complications no mess
there he's still out of time on the
clock whoa now left
yeah exactly goodness yeah James you
said it before I could he's gone for uh
this skewer here the queen of rook in
the same line but I still believe this
is what Magnus wants he may lose some
material the eval bar saying that
artemia was better and he is objectively
right but practically speaking this does
give Magnus more chance to win as I said
before even if means he might lose the
game yeah total mess I guess now you do
have options you could consider for
example taking this Pawn even if you
move your queen out the way I'm not sure
where then yes white can win material
but the white king act uh is slightly
vulnerable long term sorry he's done
everything right he's done everything
that feathersev didn't do he's kept
control when necessary and that's when
mistakes happen
wow okay he's moved his Queen I'll tell
me if he did get her out the way of that
attack the black queen was threatened as
well she did scoot out the way as well
but suddenly you can go and grab the
black Rook but it does come at the cost
of your beautiful dark Square Bishop
with white I do fear on the dark squares
that long-term Magnus will get some
counter play will have some tricks the
black dot Square Bishop doesn't look
great right now but imagine it coming to
life imagine the black dark Square
Bishop parked on the Square like E5 in
the center Magnus will surely try and
keep the Queens on if possible there are
some tricks there that he has to
navigate
can you keep the Queens on it might take
on H3 first though I mean can you take
on H3 try to open a g file with a smile
like you know this it could be possible
take on H3 and then take on G2 we're
about to see very nicely navigated the
complications uh by our time you have
there and Magnus takes the right
decision in this one to trade the Queens
keeps the bar where it is but it looks
like our Tamia is the one with the
advantage there is no attack now he has
the extra exchange there are weaknesses
on the queen side if anyone's winning
this it's got to be white
yes I don't know what else uh to add it
looks pretty safe right now if the
queens were still on the board the
reason Magnus could have been optimistic
was because the white king is really
really open but without the Queens
there's no way to ever attack it and at
the right moment on tap is that Rook
exchange the white Rook can land on A8
trade off the black rug no danger uh
action we've seen so far he doesn't even
want to trade off Rooks he's Mr
ambitious right now he hits that black
Bishop which has to move and only then
will he decide what to do next still
full control for white I do say you
sometimes slip up when you're close to
that result when you can see the
Finishing Line right what can Magnus try
if magnus's dark Square Bishop does get
back into the game maybe but there we go
Rooks are off the board oh wow and
Magnus just has to don't take the B6
spawn that's the only trick in the
position Bishop C5 check would be an
absolute disaster that is a nasty fork
in the position a double attack hitting
the king hitting the rook and Magnus
would suddenly get to Armageddon but
that's never going to happen the white
Rook has plenty of safe squares for
example F4 and luckily the white king is
very safe in the corner because the
white Bishop protects the long diagonal
no checks no hope white should be safe
but uh wow giving up the Rook for the
bishop here I mean all he needs is a
drop
bro I'm not I'm not losing this one says
artemiev and you know zeros make it a
draw this is it icons the match he's uh
wow what a classy move if the Black
Knight does try to get into the game it
will just be chopped off uh in the near
future yep he's just got full control as
long as you don't allow that black
knight in I'm not even sure where but uh
in to create some nuisance then you will
be holding this one it should be a draw
despite being a pawn down it is the
queen side pawns that can be dangerous
all right time we have what a Flawless
way to to finish the match
just great practical choices here giving
up that rook in the end sacrificing it
back keeping everything under control
and there we have it 95 B5 has been
pushed a Magnus just delaying the
inevitable here it looks like Magnus
Carlton will be in the losers bracket
tomorrow under 30 seconds though you
need to move like what do you think oh
hey man hey you're playing with fire
here you got to make a move yeah at
least he's trying to eliminate that
remaining black Pawn on the queen side
he's going to play C4 next trade off one
set of Pawns get closer to that draw
Still logical but he should have played
it a bit quicker maybe maybe 30 seconds
run for doubt I appreciate you David
getting those nights off the board and
then black gets to throw in this P4 move
then the king runs over and we see that
actually would be a winning end game he
does drop his Knight back hitting this
bishop and the problem for Magnus is
when the bishop moves the king comes and
uh yeah this Pawn is not long for the
world you could try and give a check try
to create some Fork some nuisance but
the white king would step forward I
don't think you can ever promote this
Pawn because the white Bishop's Eye line
is fixed on the H1 Square the promotion
square but at least Magnus is trying
some tricks at least he's setting some
traps and with 25 seconds vladislav
needs to dodge them getting fixed on
b3c2 but this is a big moment uh in the
chassis build Masters as Magnus Carlton
does stare at his first
first showing in the loser's bracket if
he is not able to win this one and it
looks like that move C4 it's so
important because all these ideas of
fixing that pawn on C2 and creating a
past one on the queen side with that C4
Pawn now that's gone as well four
seconds no hope lives except the clock
six now and before Pawn Falls is this
over
oh the Black Knight is coming in it
should be a draw of course white could
even just give up a piece as long as you
remove all of Black's pawns from the
board but
um yeah I'm really worried about the
clock situation actually nerves I mean
they have to be kicking in at some point
and uh now the black lights can come in
with the track
this one off
I mean that will be that'll be nothing
short of a miracle but we've seen him do
that he needs to buy a lottery ticket
wow
okay he's gonna throw in a knife
okay King G3 don't take that H3 Pawn all
the Discover checks with the Knight
landing on F2 oh but that second H Pawn
that could be dangerous like H5 H4 check
and oh my God oh my goodness what
happened H2 he's coming he's just Bishop
he goes back respect five and he takes
The
Bishop's face
oh my God
just last he needed to buy a lottery
ticket he needed to buy that lottery
ticket David he resigned you got to be
kidding me oh no what just happened she
wouldn't have to be kidding me bro well
now we see Magnus Carlton he can't
believe what just happened well no one
can this was all but over and now Magnus
lives another day we've seen him do this
over and over again